i actually i was staying in lincoln
bedroom last night and i couldn't resist
getting on the phone and i called up the
secret service as the president
feel like gone jogging tonight
in the nude
my wife and i were looking on the lawn
at midnight these guys were
fully unclothed
well it's good to have i've been
studying him since yesterday and i think
i've actually
the way to do the president is to start
out with mr rogers it's a beautiful day
in the neighborhood
then you add a little john wayne here we
go let's go over the ridge you put them
together you got george herbert walker
bush
that's the thing there
now
done i'm a nice guy
now here are some of the things the
president rickles was saying
in my dream
hi king facal of saudi arabia so
so glad you could count hope you find
the parking place for your camera
anyway may i say something here harness
can i say this from the bottom of my
heart
you gotta be the ugliest king i've ever
seen in my life
your face was a building and be
condemned
nazi time uh i love you
i know you got a lot on your mind but
try and remember next time no starts in
the car huh
feed out pastor what are you doing here
tonight you hockey park
what'd you do from the russians saying
you could take the light off
incidentally is that a beard are you
sticking your head under your armpit
anyway now
got a couple of seconds go ahead do it
let me see it
just a little just a little
that's so easy when i'm sitting right
here is it big shot
there we go okay here we go i'm not
ready for this i don't know i know
you're not ready now
no you're ready on your little show but
you're not ready here you got all week
to get ready on your little show
oh yeah here we go so it's like uh
who's going to be there i don't know oh
lowe roblox and the spice girls
yeah paula roblo and the spice girls man
do you enjoy the you enjoy the spice
girls paul nice girl spicy girls yeah
yeah yeah well they'll be on the show
yeah and uh paul do you you watch the
saturday night live show
uh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah what time is
that on now paul
i say what what time would that be out
it's like uh 11
that's live
[Applause]
what you got there let's tell you why i
want sam yeah
there you go
[Applause]
for three and a half years i couldn't
fight the best years my prime years man
for great years
three and a half years the 26 27
20 29 and a half years old you know my
best years but then
out of nowhere the state of georgia 1970
give me a title
license to come back and fight jerry
quarry ugly jerry quarry
he's he's all he got cut at the way in
and i couldn't wait three rounds boo
knock them out then i go to madison
square garden new york city oscar
bonavent is big it's awkward
it comes from argentina 15 rounds ago 15
minutes
left hook knocked that suck out and now
joe frazer is the champion
i want joe frazier the winner
and still heavyweight champion of the
world
joe frazer
[Music]
i still think i won
what if you do got me boxed in
i'm not gonna put you down
moving face to face yeah
but i will not hesitate not for a second
that's my uh
i can't believe you made a crew out of
stand in incredible shape and now you're
endorsing my inexpensive convenient
homework capital if you're done flapping
your gums
maybe you might want to give stone cold
steve austin the rattlesnake
a demonstration of your stupid tony
little push-up machine
[Music]
here it is why they say it looks more
like a round what do they say they're
kidding me how many people are going
i think i go to a pool around it looks
like a kidney yeah
yeah pancreas shaped one you know that's
good if you're stage four
you want to put your feet it's filled
with urine you're right
you'd think it's a kidney it looks like
it's a kidney shape yeah
yeah you have a little dialysis machine
where the hot tub would be you know you
just kind of clear filter that kidneys
is it offensive when i do you did you no
i either i saw you on
conan once and you did say you said
crack [ __ ] and [ __ ] several times
so then i did do a thing for confession
i did norm mcdonald as an alarm clock
and it was like this is what i wake up
hey wake up there there's a crank car
and a [ __ ] in your bed
you know if i take a paper and i start
reading it here when skip starts talking
because you know
most of the time when skip starts
talking only thing i hear is bulls you
know what i'm saying because skip
doesn't know what he's talking about
most of the time and i'm just like i
know
exactly what's going down lebron has got
to get it done
there is no way wait a minute wait a
disrespect gotta work that in
disrespectful
disrespectful blasphemous
and i'm kicked off conan is kind of like
you know you're like this and yeah when
you do this thing and then it's kind of
like
how you
[Music]
that's
doing
[Laughter]
two twos is four four
[Music]
bye